[Musique]
très bien après c'était rapide pour moi
mais c'était moi j'adorais la série donc
j'étais très fan donc c'était intimidant
d'arriver dans une série que j'avais
regardé en tant que spectatrice et sans
savoir que j'allais rentrer dans
l'histoire donc c'est troublant mais
c'est super amusant et voilà et ce
personnage il était très amusant à
construire
[Musique]
mark ruffalo il est complètement dingue
dans l indice msci la performance
d'acteur était incroyable j'ai beaucoup
aimé or boys et ça m'a donné envie de
voir plus de série israélienne parce que
je crois qu'ils sont vraiment très très
fort j'ai adoré morning show beaucoup
d'admiration pour reese witherspoon et
la façon dont elles vraiment génère des
projets je sais qu'elle avait initié
big.little live qu'elle a appris que
nicole kidman était sur le coup aussi et
qu'elle allait mais faisons le ensemble
mais c'est vraiment elle qui prend les
devants qu'ici les projets et je pense
qu'elle fait beaucoup pour l'industrie
des femmes dans l'industrie
[Musique]
ma série préférée
comment j'ai pu oublier d'en parler tu
vas unbelievable en fait c'est pas du
tout ce côté mais je suis amoureuse de
mérite weaver qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs
dans mariage story je trouve cette fois
tenu colette elle est démente la société
toni collette elle est incroyable alors
non mais alors cette série c'est une
j'ai une passion pour cette série
comprend pas pourquoi mérite weaver a
pas eu de prix pour son interprétation
je la trouve incroyable c'est une série
qui est très dur la façon dont ça aborde
le viol je trouve que c'est fondamental
la langue est le point de vue sur le
viol l'interprétation du viol
les réactions par rapport aux viols que
ce soit du point de vue des victimes des
enquêteurs enfin ces mini série et elle
est pas ce côté je crois qu'elle a été
quand même nommé aux emmy et les passes
ou côté mais elle est assez peu connu et
je la trouve est extraordinaire game of
thrones c'est la marque a complètement
lâché quelques pas du tout court que je
voudrais voir mais je n'attends pas la
suite parce que j'ai pas vu la saison 1
mais je voudrais voir à aimer distro liu
je crois que phoebe ou à l'arbre et tu
vas sortir une nouvelle série donc ça
j'ai très envie de voir
je crois que c'est ouf